ted thank you we got lots of food here
because there's always something shaking
at shake shack let's welcome sun wind
from shake shack who's here to show us
how to make the perfect milkshake but
before we get in to the perfect
milkshake tell us what you have going on
with the summer of shaq so summer shack
right now we have our uh check aids um
mocktails we have our lime agave
margarita uh we also have our peanut
punch uh which is a lemonade with a
uh grilled pineapple flavoring to it
fantastic one of my favorites and then a
watermelon mint mojito great drinks
non-alcoholic drinks you're known for
your shakes how do we make the perfect
milkshake what goes into it so the
perfect milkshake is we add our cherry
cola pop uh mix in here what we got in
here yep then we'll add a little bit of
milk to that in the cup so this is
cherry cola yes cherry cola all right
little milk add some milk in there
perfect and then we'll put our popping
candy in there what is it what is
popping candy it's like cotton pie pop
rocks oh it's pot really so we'll put
those in there is this really pop rocks
pop rocks over there there you go and
we're gonna head out to mikey mike he's
gonna spin that for you mikey mr
milkshake mikey mix it up my friend and
then we're gonna mix it up and then
we're gonna pour them right into this
cup right here for you
and just like that i i feel they're
legitimate pop rocks in my mouth right
now yeah such an old-school feeling it's
so cool and then with the um with the um
the pepsi the cherry the soda tastes to
it has a good punch and then we're gonna
just top it off wow
we need a taste test over here someone
come taste this stuff i got a mouthful
of pop rocks there you
go and what'd you put on top here what's
it when that's our uh cherry crumbles uh
uh topping that we put on there it's it
just tops it off with the right amount
of flavor for the cherry so how many
different flavors of shakes do you guys
offer oh we have strawberry chocolate or
black and white uh all our um
wonderful flavors that we have and then
we will bring out the featured ones we
currently have the triple chocolate chip
shake as well uh that's what we have up
here featured uh but now we're gonna hop
into our hot honey chicken sandwich i
have the best job in las vegas i'm
telling you that right now okay so tell
me how do we make the perfect chicken
sauce we're gonna take your chicken
there and we're gonna glaze it with this
hot honey glaze that raise it in the
bucket yeah we're gonna put it right on
the bucket for him now this is your uh
this one here yeah this nice
this is your secret sauce what is it
just hot sauce this is a hot honey glaze
on there for you
nice golden delicious and then what
we're going to do is take the habanero
mayo that's going to get a little hot
mayo right here we're going to put it on
the bun here put on the bun right on top
right on the top part there we go
everything is thick the milkshake was
thick the sauce is thick this is good
and then we're going to take a bit of
the the crispy shredded lettuce i need
my greens today so a little some lettuce
this is good put the lightest there and
i'm going to top that right off on top
right there
i like how the two sauces are separate
we combine them together here absolutely
and then you combine it and then get
ready for a nice here we go crispy
crunchy
best day ever take a big bite of this
see we got
oh my gosh sweet spicy
tender chicken this is delicious thank
you so much so we appreciate it and mike
you're the great great milkshake mixer i
appreciate it buddy las vegas now we'll
be right back we're going to eat we'll
be right back you guys